uh cash who's targeting you today
hey guys it's cash and i'm here today to
tell you about a few things that i went
through
in my targeting experience um that
led me to believe that the people i was
dealing with were not
as intelligent as they portrayed
themselves to be
so i say this because when you start
making these videos and when you're
going through this they want you to be
intimidated they want you to be scared
you know but really the reality of it is
well i did have things stolen and i did
have personal problem
property damage well the pride things
are stolen is because you worked at a
strip club and strippers like to steal
things from other strippers i mean
that's just it's a natural
circle of life dear none of it was ever
done in front of my face
nor was i physically harmed unless it
was in the instance of a drugging
and i did have a drugging um situation
happen
and it happened to me while i was out of
town um
and i also made a video about that so
nothing will happen to you if you are
of clear sound in mind you know if
anything
this whole situation has taught me to be
aware of my surroundings
at all times but i'm going to tell you
um the three things
that
led me to not be so afraid of this and
eventually i started
one it's all in your head two you're
making it up
three you're [ __ ] crazy
kind of play along with the whole
scenario
so the first one
is the time when they sent someone to my
apartment
i made a video on this i'm going to link
it down below
they sent a man to my apartment you know
his pants were undone it was like
5 00 a.m he fit my are you sure because
you're a hooker and it could have just
been a john
all i'm saying my type of person you
know
tall dark handsome but um the problem
was i'd never seen him before and he
was trying to get into my apartment at
the wee hours of the morning
so i i'm gonna take it as they were
seeing
what i would do if i would just let this
guy come in my apartment
and bang him or whatever
did you did you do that
because now i'm curious if you did that
did you do that
um but that wasn't the case i actually
ended up grabbing a knife if my door
would have been
unlocked um i don't know what would have
happened to that man
because i probably would have stabbed
him
i don't know um but the cops came
and it was after that situation
that i i kind of stopped to take i
stopped taking the whole thing like
really seriously it kind of became like
a joke
in a sense like i was if somebody came
to your house and you were fearing for
your life
how did it become a joke
how did it become a joke to you
still unalert but it kind of just became
like okay
like this is kind of getting like goofy
because before that i was like i
realized that i was in some type of
situation
okay because i did just go down there
you know i was like oh
chicago upper echelon and stamp myself
on it you know and i'm sure that i
probably stepped on some people's toes
but
while i was down there i really didn't
get the feel that there was
anybody that was that much
in power let's say so
whatever um
so i was gonna buy a gun
i
i gotta ask a question and i mean this
because i i could just be wrong here
okay
is is anybody else confused
because i'm [ __ ] confused
and i'm really trying to play close
attention to see what and i know she's
crazy now this is true but even in her
stories
i i don't understand
so
i think you know what that means
so what do we have here we got to figure
these i've been saving all these so what
do we have here
um we have
this will be cash okay
this is cash
boobs this helmet knows she's cash
forgive me i'm doing this with a mouse
so this is cash
okay all right
she is a
hooker
oh i forgot a little bush little bush
tiny little bush tiny little bush hold
on a second here actually
hold on
okay so where was i
okay my little bob ross thing going here
fluff up there we go there we go there
we go okay
so she's a hooker
that means people give her money
money to put their
penises
some pews here the pubes
in her vagina
okay do we got it so far
all right
so
we good
okay so
a man
a man this is a man
who paid money
to put the penis into her vagina as you
can see
follow his here came to her door
with an erection okay
this man was happy
because he saved enough money to get a
hooker
now cash got
scared because she's
nuts
not to be confused with the balls of the
penis so
um and yes he is a
john which for those who don't know
that's the guy who pays for the hooker
okay
she got scared she called the police
and now she's going to get
a gun
to protect herself okay that's where we
are now
let's uh let's continue the video
for protection but i i after that i was
like i'm just gonna see what happens if
if this kind of stuff keeps happening
then yes i will buy that
but it stopped happening nobody came
back to my house
or anything like that well they did send
people like walking by
at like all hours of the day which
i can't stop that because that's my
fault for living in a building where
balconies are attached to each other
that is your favorite they could just
say oh
you know this so and so had this person
over but it was just random strangers
all day every day throughout the day
just walking past my house
on the balcony terrace so um
so i didn't buy a gun
because i realized that i was playing
the game that i was playing
was more of a psychological one than
anything
so and that's what they want you to do
they want you to buy a gun because they
want to
provoke you into using it so if you're
facing this type of situation and you're
thinking about buying a gun
don't because they're not going to
physically they won't sell you one i'm
sure you're not going to get one do the
background check until
you feel like using that
gun so don't buy a gun
okay so we have to
do this here um
don't buy a gun so she didn't buy a gun
okay all right continue
um so another thing that happened that
showed me that
these people weren't very smart
is some of these people came down to
actually
physically meet me and
[Laughter]
i mean if you know that you're you know
things about somebody and you're going
to potentially use them
against them to emotionally torture
a person and they have no idea who you
are i would think that remaining
anonymous
would be probably the smarter solution
but this person did not want to remain
anonymous
she wanted me to know who she was
so she could kind of create like some
envy or something
okay all right all right hold on hold on
hold on hold on
so another woman
let's see over here
another woman who's
hold on we gotta draw when we gotta draw
them right
has bigger boobs than cash
who i'm assuming she's jealous of
because of
because of tits
which are these here
cash has turned into a
[Music]
cia
spy
because cash is envious
of her boobs
are we there so it's t tit envy is what
this is
it's a clear case of tit envy so let's
keep following along
keep following along between her and i
and there just was not never one never
will be
and that's it um so
with saying that when you're meeting new
people
do not tell new people that just show up
in your life
anything about you lie what you want
your goals your dreams anything that you
want
tell them the exact opposite of
what you actually want because
i found that in this experience new
people that were coming into my life and
very interested in me as a person
were just a means to um find out what i
wanted now did i tell these people the
truth
probably some half truths in there but
not exactly
i don't know what's happening i want it
i i don't know that was my first thing
or that was like i knew something was up
with these people i just couldn't put my
finger on it
but now hindsight like i know exactly
why they wanted to meet me why why why
why why why
all that stuff why why situation number
two
and this is where i was like all right
these people like
obviously come on
so where i'm going to myrtle beach with
this girl
okay i'd work with this girl for a while
all right all right
hold on
hold on she's going to just make some
little trees here some happy little palm
trees
all right we're gonna get some little
palm trees here
so she's going to myrtle beach
okay which is a why
trash
beach myrtle beach is a white trash
beach okay
so it's a white trash beach
okay that's what myrtle beach is she
went with her friend who i'm assuming
now
is this person the one she's jealous of
who's now a cia asset
hold on a second
and by the way i'm really i'm really
sorry if you from myrtle beach
okay anyway um
this is her [ __ ] god damn it
this is her friend
all right who's also probably a
hooker okay so she's jealous of her tits
she she went with her friend they both
went
to white trash beach together which is
weird because wasn't she just in [ __ ]
uh
iowa okay so here's where we are
there we go uh
let's continue
so i felt comfortable traveling with her
now when we get to the airport
this girl starts rummaging through her
bag
okay we're already late for this flight
i'm a very prompt person
i wanted to get on the flight i already
had already paid for the hotel room
i just wanted to go okay so i kind of
just left her
back there to dig through her suitcase i
was like
if you don't make it meet me there in
the morning because she had
this guy this guy just showed up out of
nowhere
and you know he offered for us to stay
at his place
that night i was not trying to do
because you're a hook
calm down royce that's why we have a
diagram it's because you're a hooker
so another john i'm not going to draw
another john so
see what we'll do is we'll go times
two so there's two john's now okay
wanted to again as you're looking here
pay them so you look to the right here
she wanted to
give them money to put the penis
in their vaginas okay
you're looking at it all right
that's what you are so therefore men are
going to proposition you
for that it's pretty simple
do that um so i just kind of just left
her back there and i said meet me there
in the morning
so i cut the whole entire uh
line for security which was very long
and i'm trying to get to this gate
how did you cut the line the tsa stops
the whole entire line that i'm in
and starts to search and root through
this woman's bag
now this woman wasn't going anywhere
international or anything like that she
had
closed liquor which i'm pretty sure that
you can bring onto a plane
in a bag and this woman this tsa agent
was just
taking this stick and just like
poking in the bag yes they do that and
not even
searching for anything or really looking
in the bag just like looking at me
and poking the stick and looking at me
and like
it was just so uncomfortable and then as
soon as my gate closed for myrtle beach
was when they stopped the poking of the
stick they let me go through
and the gate had closed like literally
once i stepped you were late to a flight
because
doing the bob ross thing i have to be
calm like bob ross saying i apologize
i'll calm down
you were late to the flight
okay you were
late
to your flight
because you were
hung
over you were late to your flight
because you were hung over but for some
reason
you think that hung over
equals
c
i a
but i hate to tell you something
it does not it does not equal that
over to the gate they were like
you can't go on so i'm stuck
not too far from miami i'm in fort
lauderdale but
the girl because of her non-punctuality
um offered to pay for my flight if i
missed it
the next day which that was very nice of
her she actually did the right thing in
the situation
but it does not help the fact that i was
basically forced to stay at somebody's
house
that i did not know she stayed
oh my god in [ __ ] heaven
she stayed at the john's house
because she overslept from being
hungover
and she [ __ ] him
and she's saying that is an
international cabal as someone pointed
out in the chat
why she ended up [ __ ] the guy
and you're right it's now with john
times three
now this would have been fine um
but the problem with it was
okay so i
have i like art
okay so tell me why when we walk into
this person's house
every single artist that i like
is in this person's house supposedly his
friend was an art dealer the art was
probably stolen
i don't know so here i am staying in
this
random okay hold on
stranger's house full of this high
priced art
that could potentially provoke an
emotional
response from me so
now
i'm running out of space here folks
she believes that the guy she's staying
at
i'm running out of room okay we we'll
give draw an arrow here
the guy she's staying at is in
maybe i can make more room hold on a
second
i don't want to have to clear this if i
don't have to
whatever the guy she's staying at is
from my drawing ease is really difficult
oceans 11.
he is an art thief okay he is an art
thief
and the reason that this guy had all the
art that she like is because her taste
in art is
that of a
basic
[ __ ]
she likes basic [ __ ] artwork and it's
not
that the dude is from oceans 11.
okay we following we're not a room here
folks
because some of the art was art that i
shared in an apartment
with someone that i had dated previously
so i'm in this apartment and this was
probably the most
um violating
experience i would say just because i
was taken out of my comfort zone
for so long i was basically staying
overnight
at somebody's house that i had no clue
who they were
why did you do that nobody made you
you were late to your flight because you
were hung over and you stayed at
somebody's house that you don't want to
nobody made you you put yourselves in
these situations
and you're blaming it on some sort of
international [ __ ] conspiracy
and you know this art was supposed to
brandon david's right the art was just
framed movie posters
elicit some type of crazy balls right
and he had ikea furniture like i do
emotional response from me or something
i don't know
but um i did get out of
that situation which and you're going to
say how
how are they not smart for doing that
they kept you from going on your plane
i'm not a tsa expert but i'm pretty sure
that's illegal
to do if you don't have an actual reason
to stall somebody and hold them from
getting no they they could absolutely
randomly screen you whenever they want
100 because of the patriot act they
could randomly train you whatever you
want you're not a legal expert you're a
hooker
so let's get that out of the way they
could screen you whenever they [ __ ]
want cash
that's absolutely within their purview
to do that
um what you should do is what
responsible people do
and get to the airport an hour and a
half
before your flight maybe two hours if
it's busy what i do
normally
uh instead of now saying that the reason
this is this is like
woman excuses but on and i know it's a
catchy kitschy phrase but i'm going to
say it anyway
on steroids right where
there's women that blame everything on
other people and all that's everything
everybody else's fault
but this is amplified to a level i've
never seen in a human being
every notice that everything that's
happened nothing is her fault
her getting late to the plane not her
fault her choosing to go to a guy's
place not her fault
her having sex for money not her fault
on a plane so that's legal that's number
one
number two um i still have the address
of that house
and there was millions and millions of
dollars i don't know about millions but
at least thousands and thousands of
dollars
in art millions and thousands is a very
big difference
that house so if i was
you know they know i'm not a shady
person obviously but
if i really wanted to
come on so that was number two hello
if you really wanted to you would have
stolen the art
oh how stupid are you so that's what i
think
every time i watch your videos lady how
stupid are you
[ __ ] so i just took a picture with
one of the pieces of art that i shared
in the apartment with
the person that i dated so i it was just
more comical to me than anything so that
was number two so number three
at this point i'm like okay i'm not
scared
anymore um i actually started playing
along at this point now she's playing
along we're seeing
a uh no refund policy so people that
would call me
and try to cancel and stuff i would just
keep their money because i would tell
them that there's
no no refunds with this because of
competing agencies and things like that
sorry i have to brush the hair out of my
eyes because i can't believe what i just
heard
she's a hooker with a no refund policy
and she keeps their money
yeah competiting that's how do you say
it that's how i say it her i say
otherwise not to be [ __ ]
so she's a hooker and look this isn't me
because i want to be clear here
i'm not disparaging her by calling her a
hooker
she's an actual hooker she's admitted to
it
you escort whatever you want to call it
she is the thing i'm saying she is
so i'm not putting her down i'm saying
she is a hooker
she's a hooker
hold on let's see here she's a hooker as
you can see here
[Music]
with a
no refunds policy
but no you're right it's some sort of
[ __ ] cia operation
they would call me and give me money
only to cancel because then i would have
to move things around
and try to just screw up my schedule
that way so i started enforcing no
refunds
and these people couldn't get their
money back so they were pissed
so that was one thing that i did to kind
of come back yeah i would be pissed too
you're right women of the night
practitioner of the world's oldest
profession i apologize the woman of the
night
there you go the myrtle beach which
jesus christ
if you've ever been to myrtle beach like
no offense if you live in myrtle beach
but it's a white trash beach
myrtle beach is [ __ ] carolina's
daytona beach
locals will get that at that it was just
basically
strategizing at this point and
i would i started playing so
this is the third thing so i make this
video
about facial recognition scanners and
how they're being used at
casinos and different places around the
world
wait ah i can't i give up trying to be
quiet i'm sorry
i'm sorry but the bob ross thing i can't
keep it up
i can't do the bob ross because i'm
getting too angry look
facial recognition now now we're talking
about
facial recognition how did we go from
you being a hooker
with a no refund policy that a guy came
to her door with his pants undone
when you went to myrtle beach and you
stayed with an art thief in the art and
the tsa wasn't letting you on the plane
because you were hungover how the [ __ ]
are we at
facial recognition
how are we here how are we here
i can't follow along
and sure enough i get a phone call
to go to the hard rock hotel and casino
now if you know anything about ritual
abuse or anything like that
they want to get the targeted individual
to casinos
to do a ritual or whatever no
no no no
no hookers work at casinos
if you're a hooker
[Music]
there's a little slot machine here
you pick up your john's
at a casino because you know those
people
probably have money
it's not a ritual
ritual thing a targeted individual or
a richly abused person at a casino
because
they're usually built on indian
reservations and things like that
so this was the same
week okay that i lost
a friend of mine a very close friend of
mine
so not only did i have the ritual the
potential ritual thing going on
that i make a video stating that i know
about this thing and i had the emotional
trigger
of my friend who that
was three years of his passing that day
so i knew that they were gonna try to
run
some type of you know operation on me
there
at this casino so what did i do
i didn't work the whole entire weekend
and i sent two girls that were working
with me
at the time named skyler and
victoria
of course one of them was named skyler
people that were working with her which
means the other [ __ ] that were working
that hotel
excuse me casino get it my friend passed
away
skylark victoria so skye wins
got it well he didn't like that very
much and they got very
angry so my targeting the next day at my
house
when i finally left because i stayed
inside the whole weekend just to like
see what would happen
i was getting bombarded on my social
medias um
and then my targeting the next day they
were not
happy like they knew they got it they
they got the point of what it was so
i'm gonna find out where she lives and
i'm gonna hire her for her services
and i'm just gonna have an intervention
i'm just gonna i'm gonna hire her for
her services
and if she's gonna walk in and it's
gonna be it's gonna be probably at a gym
it's gonna be a bunch of chairs in a
circle and we're going to have an
intervention
so after that for the next two weeks i
had their shells
texting me wanting to see pictures of
blondes because this girl was a blonde
so i would send the picture and they'd
be like oh what's her name
you know victoria so i would say that
they're the victors
just little petty things like this
little petty
childish things like this and that's how
i was like you know
and this was right before i left i was
like do i really want to spend the rest
of my life
playing these games with these immature
children like these
stupid games because i could have stayed
down there they probably would have
killed me
eventually because i would have pissed
them off so bad because i was just like
everything they were doing i had
like the perfect comeback to what they
were doing
no no they probably thought you're a
[ __ ]
raving lunatic because one of your
friends is named victoria
you were saying little things in an
instant
she's doing an inside joke for herself
nobody else even gets it but her
because she thinks these people were
targeted individuals
i don't even [ __ ] know anymore
[Music]
so that's why i say um
don't be afraid it's more of just like
intimidation
these are very childish people they're
not that smart
um and eventually you'll get to a point
where
you can kind of have fun with it a
little bit you don't want to stalk them
you don't want to use their tactics
to get them back
because it only makes you look crazy
they want you to do that
you know so you look crazy but if any
time you get the the
tiniest chance to subtly do what they do
to them
oh my god do it it's the greatest thing
ever and go to the dry cleaners a lot
that's all i'm gonna say just go to the
dry cleaners every week go to the dry
cleaners if you can
that that really pisses them off
what
why would going to the dry cleaner do
anything
so you have to go to the
i i'm trying to figure out how we
because i'm piecing this all together
so she thinks that the
running out of space here
she thinks the dry cleaner
is
actually involved with her
friend who she thinks
is in the cia
did i get it
all right well look i hope that i've
been informative
i hope that i've helped you here i'm
going to be saving this in my uh
collages that i save here let's see here
let's uh title it
cash diagram 2.
maybe make some shirts out of these huh
what do you think make some shirts that
literally nobody gets but you guys